vendredi dernier la 46e cérémonie des
césar a beaucoup fait parler pour un
certain nombre de raisons semblent se
souvient d'une ambiance un peu pesante
de nombreuses attaques contre le
gouvernement et les messages politiques
en tous genres on a surtout le souvenir
du happening de la comédienne corinne
masiero qui veut la peau de roger la
terre mettant l'interprète du personnage
de capitaine marleau avait décidé de
venir sur la scène des césar sous le
déguisement du film peau d'âne
recouverte de sang avant de se mettre
entièrement nu des tampons hygiéniques
accroché aux oreilles
maintenant on est comme sauve tout nu
sur un petit sketch pour s'indigner
contre l'inaction du gouvernement au
sujet de la culture qui a choqué
quelques téléspectateurs et pas
n'importe lesquels en effet aujourd'hui
c'est une dizaine de parlementaires qui
ont décidé d'adresser un courrier au
procureur de la république pour dénoncer
l' exhibition sexuelle de l'actrice des
parlementaires sont toutes rattachées au
mouvement de droite
osez la france avec ce signalement
corima zéro risque une peine d'un an
d'emprisonnement et de 15000 euros
damende mais le dernier axe ne fait que
commencer mon cher alors exhibition
sexuelle comprenez vous que des députés
même qu'au rythme à dire aux injustices
c'est incroyable cette affaire y avait
ma mère qui m'envoie un message
voilà ne j'espère que vous avez pas
déchirés capitaine marleau jeu-là d'or à
l'exceptionnel et ma mère elle aime tout
ce qui est populaire
donc c'est vrai que voilà les lectrices
pour capitaine marc lalonde à jean mi
siens président de l'institut apollon et
c'est vrai que c'est un apollon parce
que je les ai vus j'ai été repéré j'ai
découvert une petite photo de vous c'est
vrai classique la pole on comprend
pourquoi
non ça n'a pas le gabarit sans déconner
merci si votre habitation et même dani
nevo parole de la france il a changé un
peu aller un peu fort si le bon sport
c'est ça va être très chaud entre les
deux a déjà d'autres tunnels ça rigolait
c'était une fois cette remarque sexiste
la rigole léché rioja josée dayan ci qui
veut nous parler dans un instant elle
sera au téléphone avec pour la
réalisatrice de capitaine marleau je
suis un petit tour vous et chez vous
j'ai envie vraiment d'avoir votre
sentiment
moi je trouve ça incroyable vous vous
trouvez gilles verdez qu'il faut
condamner capitaine marleau mais ils
savent ça vous rend fou balesi je vous
écoute ce que toutes les opinions sont
les bienvenus ici je suis désolé mais
oui par
ce que c'est condamnable parce que j'ai
regardé tous les textes toute la journée
et c'est de l'exhibition sexuelle elle
koch toutes les cases c'était en public
maintenant il n'ya même plus besoin
d'avoir une connotation sexuelle même
quand on se déshabille pour faire de la
politique un arrêt de la cour de
cassation l'année dernière on peut être
condamné
donc je suis désolée elle risque gros et
je comprends que les députés l'attaquent
je suis obligé par honnêteté de répondre
aux hug
c'est incroyable après c'est votre droit
après gérone au secours pitié dont les
parlementaires ils ont réussi la
prouesse est plus pathétique que corinne
masiero c'est quand même bravo il a
roulé sur le corps il m'a dérangé j'en
ai marre que les gens disent qu'on l'a
trouvé le pathétique n'accorda 0 à la
fin un truc à la fois non mais on a le
droit d'avoir trouvé personnellement une
atonie est ridicule en obligeant inutile
d'accord donc voilà pourquoi pas après
tout mais c'est une artiste elle est sur
scène elle est à l'olympia moi je trouve
qu'elle a raison de faire cet happening
si elle estime et la nudité pour moi
c'était son costume de scène est donc
absolument rien de condamnable et
c'était très bien comme ça voilà mais
après j'ai détesté ce cas la haskala
fait de film mais moi j'ai une question
juste monsieur b c à vous venez à
l'extérieur vous venez de lecteurs du
plateau pour dire que vous êtes pour la
condamnation de cette dame
oui week end poursuit l'ademe fois donc
je vous ai un bon je vous ai défendu et
tout achat mais là c'est juste
incroyable
vous n'avez jamais vu une femme nue je
vois ça vous choque en fait c'est un
rapport à non mais c'est pas c'est pas
le problème mais vous avez vous avez
déjà vu un homme nu
bah oui dans ça vous choisirez que
quelqu'un se met à rêver
jouer dix matches aux molières mercedes
maintenant la parole à un représentant
syndical
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre mesdames messieurs
la fédération cgt du spectacle m'a
demandé de vous lire le texte suivant à
les oulamas 2010 mesdames les auteurs
les auteurs de ce bon merci alors bien
voyez lamentable c'est lamentable ça
aussi bas c'est la vente alors ça on l'a
la limite je dirais le gall le gars est
propre les césars cette année entre
entre fin marina foïs qui qui ramassent
des crottes
mais on parle de l'aude et et l'autre
qui fait un excellent à
l'exhibitionnisme cradingue jeunesse et
voilà on peut on peut pas tout faire on
est aux césars le sait les césar c'est
quand même une cérémonie qui s'en sert
et racontait le cinéma français le
glamour l'élégance à la française mais
défendant le non seulement en france
mais dans le monde
non ça ressemble à quoi va condamner
capitaine mike weir moi c'est sympa le
jour et de vivre je suis pas pour la
condamner parce que je pense qu'elle
sait qu'on allait tout seul en se
ridiculisant l'entrain je comprends les
gens qui puissent penser ça dans le sens
où ok elle était nue mais elle n'était
pas seulement nue elle était nue pleine
de sens vous savez il ya des enfants qui
regardent ce genre de programme en
famille et je peux comprendre qu'aider
des parents qui ont été énervé de
laisser leur glace devant la télé voyant
une femme pleine de sens n'étant plus au
pire si elle veut mais c'est le sens moi
qui m'a choqué on est on est pas là pour
faire peur aux enfants
on est là pour montrer une belle
cérémonie pour le regard des moteurs
petit héritage mais ce n'était pas le
moment alors à david guiraud de porte
parole de la france un solide quand vous
entendez jambe ici à dire il faut la
condamner
vous dites quoi non mais c'est bien jean
bessière il révèle son vrai visage parce
qu'en fait vous souvenez il faisait des
campagnes à quelques temps avec des
hashtags seins nus sur les plages parce
que soi disant on est envahi par les
burqini donc pour lutter pour le compte
le burqini fallait que les femmes elles
soient à poil sur les plages pour lutter
mais par contre quand il ya une personne
qui fait un discours politique parce que
ce qu'elle fait qu une nation derrière
elle veut faire passer un message
l'ail ou du parcours il faut qu'elle
sera vite gens visitait les combats vous
allez voir comparer les appareils les
seins nus sur les plages de choses assez
assez assez silencieux et je me crame va
passer la zec ratko assez sépaq radio et
en plus on me ferait chier
les métiers de beaucoup de fans non non
non jean marc johnson son corps
nathalie dahon sont comme ça elle fait
un message politique parce qu'à la peau
d'âne parce qu'elle dit que dans le
monde de la culture il ya un problème et
je tiens à vous dire qu'aujourd'hui là
ce soir il ya 60 lieux culturels qui
sont occupées par des intermittents et
pas que par des intermittents
d'assurance vous allez deux dedans il ya
des restaurateurs il ya des gens
derrière les d'agnostiques une chance à
une masure au japon il a quand même ce
que fait l'allemagne héros c'est qu'elle
permet qu'on en parle parce qu'on n'en
parle pas beaucoup de ces gens qui sont
en souffrance avait le mot d'ordre
aujourd'hui dans les théâtres occupée
c'est là que c'est contre la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
il ya huit cent mille chômeurs dans ce
pays qui vont perdre 20% de leur
allocation ils sont responsables de leur
situation les noms mais justement je
vais voir tourisme à 0 est la raison de
votre entrée à la regarder les avait
jamais de guerre juste d'arriver aux
gens mais il ya deux minutes j'aimerais
qu'on est sur le sujet que vous me
l'aviez va créer je vais vous corinne
masiero doit être condamné il faut
savoir qu'il ya deux députés qui ont
demandé à ce qu'elles soient condamnés
pour ce qu'elle a fait aux césar pour
mon bon sens voire merci rappel sony de
répondre parce qu'il m'a iman humain
assure corinne matière aujourd hui mais
parce qu'en fait qu'au rythme à zéro le
laisse q si vous voulez c'est qu'elle
est dans un acte politique est une
revendication sociale
mais attendez la france assurément ce
monsieur là la famille c'est le parti le
plus revendicatif
vous êtes en fait le premier parti de
nudistes
vous parlez des ouvriers effectivement
les surveillants ont liquidé leurs mots
leur usine qu'ils perdent leur vie on
les voit pas des vins et danser derrière
des capotes et moral et non mais ça
aurait été important salon parce qu'en
fait je vais vous dire quand on parle
des ouvriers mois à chaque mobilisation
qui a eu on m'a toujours dit toussaint
les étudiants à tolbiac on leur dit on a
toujours culpabiliser et trouver une
manière de dire aux gens ah mais non ce
que votre combat est juste mais fallait
pas le faire comme ça dansait luca toni
musulin exigent les jeunes vont mal mais
le combat est jugé mme annie ps on se
réveille des night et quand où et quand
il ya des ouvriers des ouvriers dans des
manifestations je vous ai jamais vu en
par ailleurs non mais ça vous
landre air france qui sont supprimées on
leur a dit ah mais vous avez arraché une
chose dont on peut être chercher encore
il m'a dit est ce que vous comprenez que
des députés qui voudrait qu on la
condamne gibert des taureaux dit oui oui
mais monsieur excusez moi mais vous êtes
venus faire de la politique mais vous
n'avez pas regardé le dossier en tant
que tel mais non mais moi aussi j'ai
adoré ce qu'elle a fait mais doit-elle
être condamné c'est de l'exhibition
sexuelle s'est fait devant des gens des
jours et plater et surtout des
téléspectateurs possiblement des enfants
donc si vous regardez bien les textes
d'accord il est dit qu'il doit être
condamné monsieur je vous réponde sur
deux points il ya le point juridique qui
est pas le plus grave
excusez moi voulait pas dans
l'illégalité quand même la forte somme
et chauffeur de navette à dire une chose
qu'une performance artistique moi je
regardais les sectes finances au sénat
mais si ces jarres vous faites pas de
performances artistiques vous la faites
ou mais je vous demande un dans un
milieu où césar vous pouvez pas vous
faire une performance
et maintenant monsieur verdez il ya la
question du droit mais nous aujourd'hui
on n'est pas juriste notre notre notre
ce qu'on doit discuter
c'est ce que c'est moral ou pas le
chemin d'année et donc c'est pas normal
parce que déjà ça de fait et c'est le
concert des faux cul parce que roselyne
bachelot qui met pas informés rien
contre cette dame
enfin l embrasser des faces ya quelques
années ça gênait personne c'est ça peut
être un accès rigolo alors les délais et
budgets qui vous dit non vous guillaume
moi cette séquence elle m'a beaucoup
gêné mais pour autant je ne pense pas
qu'elle mérite d'être condamné des gens
nus on en voit tout le temps à la télé
on a vu hier il ya des formats qui sont
autour de la nudité il ya nuit culotté
sur france 5 est une très belle émission
dont je comprends pas qu'on se fasse que
14 c'est corinne masero que quelqu'un
qu'on dise quels doivent être condamnées
en plus et dts émis ce moule de seconde
elle était recouverte aussi pour se
cacher un peu envoyez pas tout non
franchement faut arrêter et pourquoi on
n'a rien dit pour le monsieur des
molières la caserne a justement mois
corinne madero c'est une femme libre et
je trouve qu'elle a eu raison simple
c'est choquant c'est bien sûr mais là
elle l'a fait on condamne pas tous ses
balais ou où tous ces happenings qui
arrivent partout enfants dans le domaine
de la culture où ils sont tous à poil
personnes à critiquer et le monsieur de
molière qui s'est foutu à pois il n'y a
pas eu une seule plainte contre lui
ce qui veut dire que nous régressons
chers amis que la bien-pensance
malheureusement reprendre du terrain et
que c'est pas bien mais c'est ce jeudi à
propos de jean bessière
je vous le dis on arrête pas de me dire
on n'arrête pas de nous dire qu'il faut
lutter pour en fait ce que vous aimez
passer les femmes libres les femmes sont
libres dans ce pays elles ont le droit
d'utiliser leur corps comme moyen de
revendication politique dans quelque
chose qui a ordre de la mise plutôt à
défendre les femmes vous allez je suis
très surpris vous défendre vous aimez
pas les femmes ils sont libérés la
liberté des uns s'arrête là où commence
celle des gt déjà et désormais par
l'adsl c'est un spectacle qui a régné
hier mais s'avoue dollars isabelle
moreau doit être condamnée évidemment
non pour moi
faut-il oublier le plus vite possible
cette séquence évidemment pour moi oui
la preuve contre moi ce que vous dites
moi j'en ai marre que l'on prenne pas la
gueule comme si elle avait réussi son
coup à la fin de sa prestation les gens
auraient dit quand même c'est formidable
car déjà on dit à la fin des césars
merde ces gens là où le reste de la sai
et là ils ont moi je vais vous dire ce
qu'ils me ce qui me rend fou aussi dans
ce pays c'est corinne nasiru tout le
monde disait elle est formidable elle
fait 7 millions de téléspectateurs
étaient millions elle a énormément de
succès je vois que c'est quelqu'un qui
voit là que j'aime j'aime bien je la
connais pas mais de ce que j'ai vu
d'elle des cartouches aime son parcours
et comme d'habitude il y en a plein qui
veulent la lyncher maintenant aussi je
pense aussi par jalousie parce que ça me
fait chier qu'elle cartonne et que
maintenant les troupes exposés trop aimé
et c'est toujours ce qui se passe sur la
seo lui-même
bah oui on va on va encore taper sur
voilà une nouvelle idole voilà qui
corrige et voilà en face à la dernière
partie des missions de ce conte à josé
d'ailleurs et je vais vous écouter david
aussi là dessus we dance we david non
mais très rapidement mais corinne masero
elle porte un message c'est pour ça qu'à
l'attaqué prix parce qu'elle a fait une
performance et son message je vous je
vous supplie de l'entente dans c'est le
message de centaines de milliers de gens
voire de millions de travailleurs dans
ce pays qui vous disent qu'aujourd'hui
on a un gouvernement qui se bat contre
la mort liée au qu'ovide ok c'est bien
faut lutter contre la mort mais c'est
que la moitié du chemin ça faut 6 bat
pour la vie j'ai aujourd'hui nos vies
qu'est ce qu'on fait de nos vies
regardez moi je suis hier j'étais à
paris à 19 heures je rentrais du boulot
en retard déjà fallait que je vérifie si
j'ai bien l'attestation etc on est dans
un climat bon y'a personne dans les rues
je suis dans ma ville est ce qu'on fait
de nos vies oui mais en fait qu'on
aurait pu organiser et ce qu'elle dit
corinne masiero c'est qu'on peut
organiser la société différemment car
s'il n'ya pas de cherbourg et dans la
vie à la culture ya les moments de
bonheur et on ya droit on à josée dayan
l'arrêt
that he is vraiment un ré talentueuse
qui avec nous au téléphone et ça c'est
important d'avoir son avis là dessus
parce que moi oh là personnellement je
vous dis je trouve ça vraiment
pathétique voilà ce qui se passe là
autour de corinne masiero et de
capitaines marleau bonsoir josée dayan
merci bêtement quant à pierre il est
bien pris de m'avoir invité au téléphone
bana ba ça me fait plaisir parce que
c'est vrai que franchement se trouve
cette histoire complètement folle moi
c'est pas qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous mais au moins je vais vous dire je
suis comme vous je prends cette histoire
complètement folle je n'ai pas
l'habitude de polémiquer je ne suis pas
sur les réseaux sociaux
et comme disait mon marché quand on
dispute avec un saut en lui cette
toujours mais là les espaces avec les
députés et me sens tellement ridicule là
je n'ai pas envie de céder j'ai envie de
venir ici qu'ont subies ridicule on est
en train de vivre une période
épouvantable avec ce qu vide avec ses
morts avec les réanimations opératrice
des rares et d'un seul coup le clip est
vraiment 2 et des vrais pros les vrais
problèmes dans les nôtres il va aller
faire une polémique pour éviter pour eux
dire qu'il faut envoyer corps et de
l'aviron en prison mais c'est super
league
moi je voulais trop de gens qualifiés
agréé pied de parler avec vous ce soir
je le fais moi je vais vous dire ce que
j'en pense
je pense une fois de plus et c'est ça
qui me dégoûte mois ils vont ce que vous
dit ce qui fonde la polémique là-dessus
ils se servent de la notoriété de la
popularité de corinne masiero pour qu'on
parle d'eux et pour essayer de buzz et
on est dans une société du buzz on va
pas mentir et même les hommes politiques
les députés
ils veulent avoir du buzz autour d'eux
les deux ou trois qui ont fait ça ils se
disent tiens on va parler de moi parce
que je vais faire un coup d'éclat et ça
c'est grave c'est grave parce que le
mérité de la nation le rôle c'est de
faire des réserves
aujourd'hui il ya 10 millions de
personnes qui sont au chômage ont fait
menacé par messi est ce qu est ce que
vous dites sur la réforme de l'assurance
chômage vous je suis je récupère
moratoire avec vous entièrement d'accord
avec ce que vous dites je trouve qu'en
effet c'est un un député un sombre
députés que personne ne connaît et qui
permet de se faire une espèce de fuite
aurait eu en attaque encore et je trouve
ça d'une lâche et d'une stupidité
absolue
d'autre part on connaît la position trop
ri on sait qu'ils allaient on sait son
courage
pour à toutes les opinions je vais le
lui ai dit mais elle a au moins le four
a été à l'affiché et cette étonnante
vraiment fort de sa part et d'autre part
quand il explique le canton tenu
il faut aller en taule je trouve ça
tellement bête parce qu'alors il fallait
mettre tous les chanteurs de r en prime
a bien sûr exactement la comédie
musicale de l'époque
voilà mais josé est ce que vous avez
quelque chose à ajouter
mais j'ai ajouté que je remercie de
m'avoir invité merci josé le voulais je
voulais dire cela pour corinne et non
merci je sais et continuer ce que vous
faites et vous occupez pas des add des
aigris et des jaloux merci renaud qu une
gamelle et ben vous allez voir fait pour
être bien au revoir josé merci d'avoir
été avec nous josée dayan qui étaient
avec nous on va voir ce qu'on pense les
téléspectateurs d'hôtel congrès et oui
mais voilà à bord là incroyable el aroud
6% des téléspectateurs pensent que corey
may 0 doit être condamné c'est fou voilà
je vous dis même moi je coache le jeu
sans rajouter un animal a fait la
différence tout le monde a des
revendications sociales la différence
entre les classes populaires dont
parlait monsieur guy roux et un instant
et le showbiz et le showbiz c'est une
question de dignité c'est une question
de déroger désolé moi je crois que
quelles que soient les circonstances
attend il faut en effet si effectivement
conservez-les estime de soi et la
dignité ce qu'elle n' a perdu mais voilà
est une artiste mais c'est bien connu à
définir quand une en hiver quand tu vas
rien laminoir quand une analyse et moi
finir mais non mais je peux pas voulu
faire dans une artiste croit pouvoir
nous imposer sa nudité pathétique comme
argument sociale c'est une forme d'art
et birth d'accord les aider c'est une
forme de mépris pour les téléspectateurs
amateurs alors haut rhinoise heroes
c'est pas le showbiz capitaine d'arles
au royaume pickton marleau que son père
qui travaillait à la mine sa mère mais
elle vendait en mélangeant d un congé
pas fier elle a été elle a aussi des
halles a dit que j'allais c'est tentant
mais elle a vécu à la rue corinne
alapage.com couturier mais elle a passé
la barre des cols comme vous l ai pas du
tout temps mais n'avaient pas ce
qu'elles gagnent madame non monsieur
messien corinne masiero c'est une femme
du peuple d'accord et c'est tout ce que
je vous dis et que les gens soient
chauds qu'il est je peux le comprendre
mais maintenant des cinq rois c'est le
rôle
le rôle de la culture c'est aussi
parfois de vous choquer nous voudra
faire peut l'être vous dire écoutez ya
un problème il ya 61 occuper la crise
sociale est ce qu'on peut parler de ça
et elle l'a fait elle a raison
mais matt et là on en parle vous auriez
latine justice une femme s'était mise
sous tutelle peuvent et sur l'un pour
appeler pour insulte pour appeler à ce à
voter pour marine le pen
ça m'étonnerait sting liquidités là
c'est parce que politiquement c'est
votre bord ça vous arrange et ses
partenaires de tous les français les
photos fait et cause pour elle mais si
ça avait été dans les mêmes conditions
c'est toujours du mal à savourer c'est
toujours les jambes et a juste jean
message en mai sert donc vous vous êtes
pour une condamnation pour corinne
masero quelques mois je trouve à ce
jeune homme et moi je crois que la
condamnation elle doit surtout venir du
monde du cinéma lui même c'est à dire
qu'effectivement si la nudité c'est
quelque chose qu'elle affectionne et
qu'elle goûte il faut l'envoyer dans un
an dans un ferr dans un club de strip
tease globo gilles verdez importe quoi
mais ce qui je suis pas étonné du
pourcentage
parce qu'en fait les gens et moi
j'essaie de dissocier ce que je ressens
moi même et les gens se sont sentis
agressés les legends a pris sa secte
comme une démonstration de l'onu dit
déjà la trace du monde du public qui
n'avait rien demandé je vous signale
quand même que exhibition sexuelle ses
marques et aujourd'hui c'est assimilé à
agression sexuelle c'est pour ça
qu'elles risquent un an de ses sources
et 15000 euros elle n'aura pas à moi
j'ai semé moi non plus je vous dirais
oui nous à 0 moi j'espère qu'elle va ça
va se tasser pour elle oui parce que là
c'est devenu la nouvelle cible de tout
le monde bien c'est moi ça me fait de la
peine parce que je pense que c'est
fondamentalement fondamentalement
quelqu'un dernier mais elle ce week-end
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui a apporté
quelque chose dans le métier et qu'elle
a un très gros talent et j'espère voilà
qu'elle va elle va se concentrer sur ça
qu'il va pas voilà ce se prendre la tête
avec tout ce qui se passe autour d'elle
juste un petit mot derrière corinne
masero il ya des gens c'est le monde de
la culture c'est les gens qui nous
magali d'ailleurs sur ce plateau aussi
aux cetc les gens qui vous qui vous a
bissé les gens qui portent la caméra il
ya plein de gens précaires en fait dans
cet univers là derrière corinne masiero
ça et encore une fois je vous le dis moi
je peux comprendre que les gens soient
choqués mais ces deux buts parce qu'en
fait ou on n'en parle pas sinon et c'est
ce que j'essaie ce qu'elle a voulu faire
ce qu'elle a elle explique d'ailleurs
elle a donné une interview est très
récemment
c'est que si elle ne le fait pas eh ben
on n'en parle pas et donc en fait les
les centaines de milliers de français il
va y avoir huit cent mille français qui
vont prendre une réforme dans les dents
des gens qui sont au chômage
et vous savez que le chômage atteint 10
mille aux 10000 à 15000 personnes par an
seulement